good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you're very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on Sky news
reports the PM and the chancellor are at
loggerheads over the economy this
morning they have much to be concerned
about the pound is tanking and some
mortgage lenders are holding on to their
money as interest rates are predicted to
travel if that sounds like a bad week at
the office for dining Street it
deteriorated further last night when the
world's lender of Last Resort that's the
IMF joined a growing backlash against
last Friday's mini budget we'll speak to
a Liz trust supporter laborers Lucy
Powell the finance sector and some of
those most impacted by the cost of
living crisis it is Wednesday the 28th
of September Sky News reveals tensions
between the Prime Minister and her
Chancellor over how to respond to the
market tailspin caused by the budget
interest rates are projected to rise to
more than six percent by May after a
warning for the bank of England's Chief
economist
prices in the shops are going up too new
research shows that fresh food like this
is up by 10 percent
also ahead European leaders say major
gas pipelines in the Baltic Sea were
sabotaged and demand an investigation
postal workers announced 19 days of
strikes affecting some of the busiest
shopping days of the year in the run-up
to Christmas
[Music]
he'd like
into the stratosphere David Bowie's
handwritten lyrics with the pop classic
Starman have gone under the hammer for
more than 200
000 pounds
also coming up on the program for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
right around the world joined by
best-selling author and former
politician Jeffrey Archer to talk about
his new book his bond with Princess
Diana and current politics also
I'm up in space
[Applause]
and then there were two Glasgow and
Liverpool a shortlisted to host next
year's Eurovision song contest we'll
hear from both of them about why they
should win
[Music]
hello everybody very good morning to you
homeowners face having to find hundreds
of extra pounds every month to pay the
mortgage experts are predicting that the
bank of England will put up interest
rates to more than six percent in the
coming months and banks are pulling
deals for new customers the pressure on
the government is only increasing with
the IMF joining a growing International
backlash and telling the chancellor that
he should scrap his tax cuts for the
high earners and as guy news has
revealed there are divisions in Downing
Street over how to respond
let's get more should be tomorrow
standing by in Liverpool for us um hi
Tamara goodness me it's not happy
reading for anybody in Downing Street at
the moment is it either 10 or 11
morning K we asked the government's
economic woes deepened last night with
this extraordinary statement from the
international monetary fund basically
saying that they were closely monitoring
the situation in the UK and urging the
government to u-turn on some of its tax
cuts now Sky News understands in
response to that the the Prime Minister
and the chancellor actually had a
disagreement about how to respond to
some of the market turmoil we've seen as
a result of the changes announced in the
mini budget at last Friday you'll
remember that at the treasury issued a
statement intended to calm and reassure
the markets by saying that the
chancellor would set out a plan to cut
the debt at the end of November in eight
weeks time now Sky News understands that
in fact the Prime Minister was initially
resistant to doing that and had to be
convinced that this was a good idea I'll
read you some of the statements that
we've that we've seen over the last 24
hours the a statement from the
international monetary fund said the
nature of the UK measures will likely
increase inequality than 23rd of
November budget will present an early
opportunity for the UK government to
consider ways to provide support that is
more targeted and re-evaluate the tax
measures especially those that benefit
High income earners so telling the
government to basically change course we
heard from the treasury who said we are
focused on growing the economy to raise
living standards for everyone and the
chancellor has announced he will publish
his medium-term fiscal plan on the 23rd
of November which will set out further
details of the government's fiscal rules
including ensuring that debt Falls as a
share of GDP in the medium term so
they're going full steam ahead and
saying that they will set out ways to
try and reassure the markets now I
understand that the chance that
quasi-quarters is meeting with heads of
various Banks today
um to tell them more about his plan uh
Bloomberg Bank of America JP Morgan
Morgan Stanley those are the sort of
names he'll be present at this meeting
he's having this morning but perhaps
more of a Shoring up job needs to be
done with Tory MPS who are already
publicly voicing their concerns over
this plan and how it comes across to
voters who are of course deeply anxious
about how they're going to pay their
mortgages okay thank you
joining us now is Charles Road director
of mortgages at UK Finance hi good
morning thanks for joining us on the
program this morning your boss the CEO
um said last week
um as far as the budget was concerned um
strong backing of the financial services
sector as being the Catalyst for the UK
economy so full of praise for the
chancellor
um do you think he still feels that way
this morning I think in terms of the um
the comments that he made at the time
yes he does what's happened is of course
the markets have interpretation in a
different way and this is where we're
seeing the turmoil coming through in the
in the mortgage markets at the moment
but what I would what I would say is
that there are plenty of mortgage
products out there in the market for
consumers looking to purchase a property
or to move on to uh take a remortgage
why do you think the markets are wrong
and that your boss is right I'm not
saying the markets are wrong what I'm
saying is in terms of
um the comments that my boss made at the
time David posting you've made at the
time was the reflect reflection of
um the the budget that the uh the
chancellor announced and the the steps
that he was taking to uh to help
consumers in terms of the cost of living
challenge they were facing and also to
make sure that the UK financial markets
are an attractive place for firms to do
business it hasn't worked there has it
right at this stage um you know that the
markets are interpreting it differently
um we we are seeing a little bit more
stability coming through into the market
so um over the last couple of days are
we or in what way well in terms of the
uh at the Pounders firmed up against the
dollar a little bit over the last couple
of days no it hasn't I think it's um was
it 106 107 overnight it was 107
overnight but it's picked up from the
103 that it was the three was on the
Asian markets wasn't it wasn't actually
here in the UK so it's not really picked
up at all has it and the international
monetary fund the lender of Last Resort
as we know has stepped in to say
um that it's he's on the wrong quarter
and he needs to change direction yeah I
can't comment on the now on the the
Chancellor's comment and the chancellors
um uh decisions at this stage and I know
that the IMF have commented overnight
and that's for something for the
government to to pick up rather than UK
yeah but the impact on your business has
been astronomical hasn't it in what way
in that people can't get mortgages I
mean of course there are mortgage
mortgage products available but we're
seeing some of their big names like
Skipton and Halifax and virgin money are
saying we're not sure where this is
going so we're going to pull out for now
or offer different style mortgages that
they didn't previously there are still 3
000 mortgage products available
um on the market there's plenty of
choice for consumers and whether they're
looking to purchase a home or to
remortgage at this stage
um so there's certainly no shortage of
mortgages there are still there is more
mortgage on offer at this stage than
there was at uh in the start of 2020 the
pandemic when a similar issue occurred
in relation to reduction in mortgages
what are the interest rates looking like
how much is it going to cost people
in terms of taking out a new mortgage at
the moment it depends on in terms of
their loan to value and in terms of the
the borrower one of the things that we
would say and we would encourage all
consumers is to uh to speak to your
mortgage advisor and independent
mortgage advisor early if you're looking
to remortgage they will be able to find
the best product for you if you're
finding that you're in financial
difficulties then we would encourage um
borrowers whether it's secured or
unsecured mortgage borrowing to speak to
your lender at an early stage they stand
ready to help they've got a good
experience in this and they they want to
ensure the consumers get the right
product for their circumstances Bank of
England suggesting that interest rates
could go up to six percent what will
that mean for mortgages I can't comment
on what future speculation is in terms
of mortgages what I would say is that
everybody who's taken out a mortgage
since 2012 has been stress tested
they've had a stress test above three
percent above the lender's standard
variable rate to ensure that where there
is Market turbulence or movement in
markets that um there is an elements of
of affordability built in there and
that's a learning from what happened
before the financial crisis in
2007-2008. if mortgages do if interest
rates do go up next year to you know
five six seven percent I'm asking you to
comment specifically on the number what
will that mean for people who have
um fluctuating more as opposed to fixed
rate what would that mean for people who
you know have a mortgage that fluctuates
with the market so in terms of
performance on a variable rate mortgage
or track a mortgage one of the things
that we would say is again always speak
to your mortgage advisor to see where
there's a better product that's
available for you but in terms of the
um banks are there ready to help
borrowers who are facing financial
difficulty and will help customers
switch to a fixed rate product if that
is right for them at that particular
time and their their circumstances how
long have you been in the business in UK
Finance right and UK Finance I've been
here for two and a half years I watched
in the mortgage market for over 20 years
and how would you compare what's
happening now with the rest of your
career in terms of what I've seen before
I've seen I've seen it worse um so in
terms of the in terms of the late 1990s
and also in terms of the after the
financial crisis when we so array a
significant reduction in house prices
and also in terms of an increase in
unemployment at that particular time as
well I'm also just going back to your
CEO he said further tax changes and
ambitious regulatory reform are required
to capitalize on this bold first move so
you wanted to see taxes cut further one
wonders what impact that would have
yeah I mean I can't comment on those
people we can represent the business so
yes yes I I represent the business but
in terms of in terms of the tax tax cuts
that he would like to see there would be
tax cuts and changes to encourage
firms to invest in the UK and to
encourage investment
um at all levels of the economy to help
the government in terms of their agenda
in relation to leveling up and also in
terms of making sure that we have a
vibrant and buoyance economy which
encourages investment both from overseas
firms and also from UK firms so as far
as UK Finance is concerned the
chancellor is on the right track
when UK Finance sits at the moment we
are supportive of what the government is
trying to do
um and we will are also supportive in
terms of our members in terms of the
mortgage there are mortgage firms as I
said at the beginning there is plenty of
mortgage on offerings in the Market at
the moment and we want to ensure that
borrowers have Choice which they do have
if they're looking to remove some more
money yeah and that's a reflection of
marketing economics rather than a
reflection on what the mini budget's
done
um in terms of where we are in terms of
this current phase in the cycle things
will start to level out we are seeing
that firms have those firms that have
withdrawn their products are putting
them back on the market this morning
okay okay so as far as Virgin Media is
concerned as far as Halifax is concerned
I think the other one was skipped and if
I'm not wrong they're all going to be
back on the market this morning that not
not necessarily those three films a
number of firms are coming coming back
with new products this morning um and
towards the end of this week as well
okay it's great to talk to you Charles
thanks so much thank you for joining us
thank you looking at the front pages for
you this morning let's start with the
telegraph should we the front of the
telegraph carries a warning for the
Prime Minister Liz trust from the IMF
reverse tax cuts is what that says very
different to what we're hearing from UK
Finance Market turmoil requires tough
action from Boe its Chief Economist
warns that reads the front of the
financial times for you today the eye
leads with more on the budget backlash
pm and quateng ignored officials who
warned of markets turmoil is their
headline house prices warning as loan
rates rise sharply reads the front of
the times referencing the Credit Suisse
analysis that property value may fall by
15 percent
and the sun covers mortgage fears over
inflation Rises as they say
bricking it and while the guardian reads
A labor moment as sakir starmus sets out
his plans for their return to power
new figures out this morning reveal more
pain for consumers the rise in prices in
shops and supermarkets in Britain has
hit its highest rate on record
the British retail Consortium Nielsen IQ
index shows over all Forgive Me overall
shop inflation was up almost six percent
in September food prices are up more
than 10 percent on last year a rise
driven partly by the war in Ukraine
which is driving up the price of things
like animal feed fertilizer and
vegetable oil and fresh food products
costing a record 12.1 percent more than
they did last year
he's standing by for is it a green
grocers in dulwich in southeast London
this morning showing us carrots at the
start of the program we can see lots of
other fresh fruit there as well all on
the up when it comes to cost shingy good
morning
good morning Kate that's absolutely
right those figures are Stark and
they're being driven by things like the
weak pound which we've been talking
about constantly in our programming as
well as issues like Energy prices and
the increasing cost of transporting
these lovely products that we have here
at this green Grocers and I'm joined by
Matt who's the director of marvelous
Greens and Beans to talk a bit more
about the pressures they're facing so
Matt tell us a bit about some of the
products that have gone up in price the
most
um so overall some prices have gone up
throughout the year it's been a bit of a
difficult year overall for fruit and
vegan for Fresh Products
um Stark prices have increased mostly in
dairy products so milk cheese we've seen
them go up a few times this year maybe
two three times this year two three
times more for milk yeah what's driving
that
um often production costs uh the feed
for the animals it's getting very
expensive for the farmers who the farms
and so obviously that cost comes to us
we're trying to absorb that cost as much
as possible so it doesn't go to the
consumer and to the customers but it is
there how do the customers feel about
paying way more for their basic
necessities here some of the foods that
they need well as I said we try to
absorb that cost as much as possible we
very much see ourselves as a community
green grocer so we have to take the hit
a little bit we're a bit concerned about
you know other costs like fuel
electricity that's going to be coming
soon but generally as long as we are in
a good relationship with the community
they understand they are understanding
and they are supportive
um but you know for some people it can
be too difficult thank you very much for
that Matt so there you have it is a
picture of spiraling costs which are
impacting the people selling the goods
but also the people buying the goods as
well okay
okay thank you thank you
well the chancellor question will try to
reassure investment Banks today after
the bank of England signals sharp
interest rate Rises could be on the
cards
joining us now is the conservative MPS
Sir John redwoods and Liz truss
supporter hi it's good to see you thanks
for joining us on the program this
morning why do you think that the
markets have reacted so badly to the
Chancellor's mini budget
well the markets globally were reacting
very badly to the Federal Reserve
board's announcement when they said they
were going to hike interest rates a lot
and we we saw a big blizzard of bonds
setting ahead of the Chancellor's
announcement and then the world
speculators and currencies who had been
raiding the Yen and the euro in in past
weeks turn more of their attention to
the pound and we saw them do a sharp
sell-off in the pound which then
reversed very rapidly to some extent on
the Monday morning markets would do What
markets want to do and these are not
things that governments should seek to
control
governments need to follow
counter-inflation policies that work
which they didn't do in the previous two
or three years and they need to follow
policies that promote growth my message
today is that the government a right to
see the main threat for the year ahead
as a recession not inflation because the
good news is that all the forecasters
say inflation will come down a lot next
year and the sooner the better
so how does inflation come down with
interest rates going up to the extent
that we are are being till six percent I
know what you're going to say in
response to that and I would suggest if
interest rates go up to six percent
we're going to see people not being able
to afford their mortgages and having to
hand back their homes
yes and that would be quite a wrong
policy response and I hope the bank of
England monetary policy committee is
wiser than some of these rumors and
leaks coming out because I don't think
there's any way in which we need six
percent interest rates uh their own
forecast Bank of England's own forecasts
say that inflation will be back to two
percent within a couple of years they
may be right this time that their
forecasts and I think they should be
very cautious about taking more action
because they have lurched from a
monetary policy that was flagrantly too
permissive and very inflationary so one
which is now very tight and I think it's
quite tight enough to do the job we need
to do which is to get inflation down
well then the bank of England is
independent as we know and they feel
that it's necessary to stabilize the
pound by increasing interest rates
significantly
well it's not their role or remit
stabilized account and they won't be
able to stabilize the pound uh the pound
is buffeted by huge forces in in Global
Currency markets where uh collectively
the the World Trade has trade far more
money than the British government could
throw at it the last time we had a
policy of trying to defend a particular
level of the pound it was particularly
disastrous policy it was called European
exchange rate mechanism and it first of
all gave us an inflation and then it
gave us a recession we don't want boom
bust and trying to Target the currency
would be a supreme error which would do
damage to our prosperity
not as disastrous for the pound as we're
seeing at the moment some might suggest
do you think the bank of England is
overreacting
well they haven't done anything yet and
I'm very pleased they haven't I fully
support potentially an increase in in
interest rates to six percent that's
what is being speculated do you think
that would be an overreaction yeah well
that isn't a statement to the bank of
England I'm pleased to say the bank of
England has wisely decided it doesn't
need an emergency meeting or an
emergency interest rate rise and why
would they because as I said their
forecasts are that inflation will come
back down to Target within a couple of
years and that they have already put up
interest rates on several occasions in
the past more importantly they have
stopped printing money to buy bonds
which I think was one of the
inflationary forces the bank of England
wanted to do something helpful then they
would announce that they don't need to
be selling some of the bonds that they
bought at very high prices at Big losses
they could say to the markets we now
think the bonds are too cheap for us to
want to sell any that would be very
helpful
uh okay let's talk about the
international monetary firm fund then
the uh the lender Last Resort they've
also got very grave concerns overnight
why are they wrong
well the IMF but were very wrong as was
the bank of England over the inflation
which they now rightly worry about
they didn't warn us or the other central
banks in the run-up to the big inflation
that the monetary policies in 2021 were
far too loose interest rates are far too
low and that money printing was getting
out of control and it's a great pity
they didn't warn about that now they
should be looking forward
and as the global forecasts point to
lower inflation in America Britain
Europe as do the domestic forecasts they
should be saying the new threat is
recession I don't want to see people
losing their jobs on a big scale and
income squeezed because we're in too big
a recession we should be fighting
recession of course we must be prudent
with finances but the the truth is that
if the austerity policies have their way
and we have a big recession the the
borrowing won't go down the borrowing
was sore and my fear now is the official
forecasts in the United Kingdom which
for two years greatly exaggerated the
amount of borrowing to try and encourage
a high tax policy are now
underestimating the amount of borrowing
we will be forced into doing because of
the world Slowdown
so the bank of England is out of Step
the IMF is out of Step let me put a
story to you that I've been reading in
the Sunday Times Guardian other
newspapers as well interesting to get
your take on this Sir John if you would
please at reporting that there was a
group of Liz trust supporting hedge fund
managers who attended a dinner a week
ago every one of them was shorting the
pound which means as you know but for
the benefit of others who perhaps don't
they were betting that it would go much
lower against the dollar the paper
reported several of them made small
fortunes shorting the pound the
financial conduct Authority has been
asked to investigate do you think they
should
well I I know nothing of the
circumstances of this alleged meal and
who went so now I I can't comment on
that if people have uh broken the rules
or done something wrong then of course
it should be investigated but I know no
evidence for that but I suppose you only
know if they've broken the rules if you
investigated
yes but I don't even know this meal
occurred so I'm not the person to
cross-examine on this but I like most
people uh don't wish to see people
breaking rules and if they have they
should be investigated
um okay
um how did you feel about the latest
opinion polls that we saw from yougov
Over the week well they they was done
over the weekend we saw it um yesterday
uh Tori is 17 points behind labor
well I look forward to them improving
clearly that wasn't a good poll but the
the poll that matters as people always
say who are behind in the polls is the
one that occurs when you have a general
election uh I would imagine a general
election is still a couple of years away
uh so I think a lot is going to happen
before then and I will be supporting the
government every time it does things
which raise the prosperity and freedoms
of the British people so that is shorted
away it's become more popular
yeah I'm sure that um this trust is not
going to find it mildly amusing given
that normally you do see when there's a
new leader in post they do tend to have
a polling boost in the first few weeks
don't they
well these are very exceptional times
aren't they and the the new prime
minister took over against this
background of Global Market meltdown
bombs being sold off everywhere shares
falling a lot as well as people sifted
through the the truth of what I've been
trying to tell you which is that we are
at that point where inflation is
receding as the main problem and
recession is looming and that does
require a policy change and I therefore
look forward to a rounded policy change
from this government not merely some tax
rate reductions but also measures to
promote more investment more capacity
more domestic energy more domestic food
because we need to tackle the balance
payments deficit and measures to get
better value out of all our public
spending so that we control the deficits
in the right way
okay it's great to talk to you we
appreciate you taking the time this
morning thank you
still to come on the program for you
this morning we'll have more reaction to
the market tailspin over the past few
days that have sent the pan tumbling
speaking to Ben zaronka from The
Institute for fiscal studies
charity warns that millions of people
with asthma could be at risk this winter
because of soaring costs we'll speak to
someone with a serious lung condition
and we'll speak to the Royal commentator
Robert Hardman as it emerges there are
no plans for Prince William to receive a
formal investiture ceremony as Prince of
Wales
in other news European leaders have
described damage to the Nordstrom gas
pipe Network as an act of sabotage and
have demanded an investigation the
president of the European commission
erstra vonder Lyon says any deliberate
disruption of active European energy
infrastructure is unacceptable and will
lead to the strongest possible response
joined now from Moscow by Alex Rossi hi
Alex we don't know what's happened to
this pipe but there are suggestions that
Russian forces might be at hand
yeah it is all a bit of a mystery and it
should be said that we may never really
understand what's happened I think it is
quite clear when you listen to
everything that's being said by
officials and security agencies uh in
Europe that this was most likely an act
of sabotage it was an attack
seismologists in Denmark and Sweden
recorded uh what wasn't an earthquake
they think it was a blast uh registering
something like 2.3 on the Richter Scale
now it's thought that there were three
explosions causing three holes in these
two pipelines Nordstrom one and
Nordstrom two now certainly uh in Europe
they are pointing the finger some more
than others uh the Polish prime minister
has pretty much said that it is the
Russians that are behind this Ukraine
also has leveled that accusation at
Moscow now here it's been met with
strenuous denials they they say that
this is nothing to do with us they say
it was an act of sabotage and needs to
be investigated
rigorously so I think the big question
for lots of people is who benefits from
all of this and again it's really hard
to say who exactly does benefit from it
because these pipelines weren't
operational Nordstrom one hadn't been
used since the summer and Nordstrom 2
had never come online but there is this
concept K called hybrid Warfare and it's
something that the Americans the CIA
have been warning European leaders about
since the summer saying that there could
be an attack on energy infrastructure
and if you look at it through that prism
perhaps Things become slightly clearer
now hybrid Warfare are attacks that
happen off the battlefield think about
European economies like our our own one
it's soft and it's open so something
that could fall uh cause a drop in the
pound or the Euro for instance could
make things more difficult for people in
those countries and Sack the political
will now what happen with this of course
is we've seen the price of gas Spike
it's already extremely high when people
across Europe are fight facing a cost of
living a crisis there's an enormous
amount of inflationary pressure so
therefore it would fit into that
category I'm not saying it is that but
that of course is the speculation that
lots of people are making but certainly
the Kremlin here is denying that it was
behind this and the investigations
continue okay Alex when I thank you
also making headlines for you on the
breakfast show here on Sky news this
morning Royal Mail workers have
announced that they'll strike for 19
days in October and November in a
dispute overpaying conditions the
walkouts will cover Peak periods such as
Black Friday and the build-up to
Christmas some 115 000 communication
communication workers union members were
already preparing to walk out on Friday
and Saturday after that action was
revealed earlier this month
millions of people are being urged to
have the flu and covered vaccines ahead
of what is expected to be a bad flu
Spike this winter experts are warning
there will be lower levels of natural
immunity due to people mixing Less in
the last few years because of the
pandemic
new analysis has found flights for half
term getaways are on average 42 more
expensive than before the pandemic with
the largest rise on fares from Heathrow
to Tenerife the consumer Group which
found that passengers booking six weeks
before departure paid an average of 262
pounds more each way than in 2019 for a
family of four that's an extra 2
000 pounds
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show here on Sky News
former cabinet minister Sir John Redwood
he's been speaking to us this morning
he's defended the government's economic
policies and said the bank of England
should be very cautious about raising
interest rates
food inflation hits its highest rate on
record with fresh food products more
than 12 percent higher than a year ago
European leaders describe damage to the
north stream gas pipe Network as an act
of sabotage and have demanded an
investigation
well uh earlier I spoke to Sir John
Redwood as I was saying he told me that
inflation would be under control in the
near future and that the bank of England
should be cautious about raising
interest rates I don't think there's any
way in which we need six percent
interest rates uh their own forecasts
think of England's own forecasts say
that inflation will be back to two
percent within a couple of years they
may be right this time with their
forecasts and I think they should be
very cautious about taking more action
because they have lurched from a
monetary policy that was flagrantly too
permissive and very inflationary to one
which is now very tight and I think it's
quite tight enough to do the job we need
to do which is to get inflation down
foreign and I also spoke in the last day
to Charles Rowe he's the director of
mortgages at UK Finance the organization
which represents Banks he told me that
there are still plenty of deals to go
around after hundreds of deals were
pulled over rate rise concerns there are
still 3 000 mortgage products available
um on the market there's plenty of
choice for consumers and whether they're
looking to purchase a home or to
remortgage at this stage so there's
certainly no shortage of mortgages one
of the things that we would say and we
would encourage all consumers is to uh
to speak to your mortgage advisor and
independent mortgage advisor early if
you're looking to remortgage they will
be able to find the best product for you
if you're finding that you're in
financial difficulties then we would
encourage borrowers whether it's secured
or unsecured mortgage borrowing to speak
to your lender at an early stage they
stand ready to help they've got a good
experience in this and they they want to
ensure the consumers get the right
product
my journey is now a senior research
Economist at The Institute for fiscal
studies that's Ben zaranco hi Ben good
to see you
um what's your take on what's happening
at the moment
well I think that lots of Market
investors and increasingly International
institutions have heard from the IMF
today are thinking that there's a bit of
a credibility gap in the government's
economic plans and its economic strategy
the government took a major gamble last
week with its plant it's effectively
betting the house on growth and it's
gambling that it's package of tax cuts
and some rather vague promised supply
side reforms to the economy will deliver
substantially higher growth and make the
sums add up and I think what you've got
is markets taking a look looking at the
government's plans for the public
finances looking at the political
challenges around for example reforming
planning on making it easier to deliver
large infrastructure projects and
concluding that they just don't buy it
and that's why you're seeing uh the
following pound you're seeing much
higher costs of borrowing for the
government and the form of higher guilt
fields and all that adds up to a rather
unattractive economic picture and
there's a risk of this exacerbating
economic challenges the UK faces and a
lot rests on the government delivering a
credible and convincing medium-term
fiscal plan next month it's promised
that the 23rd of November and I think a
lot is riding on that will want to see a
credible plan where the sums at least an
attempt to make the songs I don't really
even get that last week to try and
convince markets to convince people
lending equipment money but they've got
things in hand
just been hearing from a back bench Tori
MP who was saying that the bank of
England need to keep the mitts off the
um the pound or trying to get the pound
to bounce back that's not their remit
also hearing from uh one of the guys who
represents mortgage and Loan lenders
saying that basically the his boss was
saying that the government should double
down on more tax cuts
well we have an independent bank of
England and I think one thing that
potentially markets might be worried
about is the prospect of the fiscal
authorities leaning on the bank of
England and trying to do whatever
pressure they can bring discourage them
from increasing interest rates to the
level they see appropriate the bank's
job is to transfer inflation back down
to Target that's what they're tasked
with and that's what they'll do I don't
think it's especially helpful for
government authorities to try and
interfere with that task Aussie cortex
said last week that the independence of
the bank of England is sacrosanct and I
think that in terms of uh whether my tax
cuts are on the way we had the chance to
promise of the weekend that there's more
to come well at the moment we're already
set to see uh borrowing stay extremely
high well above 100 billion pounds into
the medium term back through beyond the
rest of this Parliament and there are
forecasts the economy and the public
balances that would see debt on a
steadily Rising path the chancellors
promised that debt will be falling as a
share of national income so we don't
need now is a plan for how that's going
to happen more tax cuts I'm afraid we're
going to make that more difficult
instead you might have to be thinking
about whether unless you can secure a
miraculous increase in the rate of
growth are we looking at Rome back on
some of those tax cuts we're looking at
a painful package of spending cuts at
some point in the next few years there
are no easy ways out of this you can't
just assume your way to fiscal
responsibility what we'd like to see is
a chance to grasp nettle recognize some
of the trade-offs involved involved and
try and re-establish The credibility of
the UK's fiscal regime yeah I mean the
thing that has caught the headlines is
the cutting of the top rate of interest
from 45
um of attacks I should say from 45 to 40
actually that only amounts to about two
billion pounds um I suppose it depends
which side of the fence you're on as to
whether that was a good idea or not
yeah in the grand scheme of the public
violence is two billion pounds is
neither here nor there I think it's more
a question of
um clearly there's political judgments
about whether that's a good move or not
I think it's more a question of
priorities and a question of why are you
injecting demanding to the economy at a
time when the bank of England is trying
to set any additional demand but also
this this argument that they're making
that these cuts to the top rate of
income tax will contribute to a much
faster economic growth rate for the UK
and I think the evidence is is rather
thin on the ground for that and I think
that that's what people don't buy is
that this package of tax cuts is going
to be enough to turn around the UK's
rate of need to economic growth just by
taking taxes back to where they were say
two years ago I think people just don't
buy that and the evidence just isn't
there to support it and that's why I
think there's been such a negative
reaction from some parts of financial
markets
um just to throw on the obr the office
of budget responsibility who basically
analyzed the figures and talked to us
about them either explain them or
otherwise do you think if they had been
asked for their analysis alongside this
mini budget then potentially the
government might not have been in the
pickle it's in
I think it certainly would have helped
it's a as much as anything else markets
are governed by emotions and by a sense
of direction and a sense of uh if you
like for better way of The Vibes coming
off the government and I think sacking
the treasury's top
um civil servant saying you don't want a
new set of forecasts for the economy of
the public finances even though the Obi
had said that there was one available
and ready to publish all of that gives a
sense of a desire to avoid scrutiny and
avoid what you might call expert opinion
although it's of course not Beyond
criticism
um and I still I think that it perhaps
might have helped it would have at least
said
um on the government's own forecasts it
would have almost certainly been on
track to have much higher borrowing and
debt Rising as a share of the economy
and the government would have been
forced to Grapple with that fact it
might have been forced to have some sort
of more credible plan how to deal with
that in the medium term just ignoring it
and brushing it under the carpet I think
that's what seems to panic some parts of
the financial markets great to talk to
you thanks a lot man
what impact uh what's going on at the
moment in the markets has on people day
to day well the health charity asthma
and lung UK has warned that the cost of
living crisis is leading to patients
cutting back on medicine Heating and
food the charity warned there could be a
tidal wave of Hospital admissions
joining us now is uh Ron fluid who lives
with a serious lung disease and his wife
Maxine who is Ron's carer hello Tebow
thank you for joining us on the program
Ron how are you feeling this morning
first of all well I'm feeling a bit
nervous to be honest with UK but I'm
feeling fine I'm feeling yeah fine oh
don't be nervous uh you're only talking
to me
um and talk to me about your condition
and the impact
we've seen over the last few weeks and
months with the cost of living crisis
what impact is that having on you both
well my condition is idiopathic
pulmonary fibrosis and it's scarring on
the lungs and as you can see I'm on
permanent oxygen uh the impact
the impact of the
energy crisis will be quite also what
I'm looking for Doug immensely immensely
significant you know I said yesterday in
the reports when I was working full time
and I was forced to go part-time I
adjusted to my reduced wage but now the
impact of the of the energy crisis we
can't
adjust to that figure and I have to keep
this house at a constant temperature due
to my lung condition
yeah I get that Maxine there is a limit
there isn't there a price cap on um
energy bills that come the government
has set that at two and a half thousand
pounds for two years how will that help
you
well it's it's a little bit better than
it was going to be but to be honest it's
still over doubling the bills we have
and that means we have to decide whether
we keep warm
and don't eat for cut down on what we're
eating or freeze and eat now with Ron
being on the lung transplant list and
his disease any cold in the winter can
cause an infection which could cause him
to be hospitalized which could cause him
to lose his life so to us this isn't
this is an extremely serious issue
now asthma and lung UK I know that you
have quite a lot to do with that charity
don't you and they've helped you in the
past what are they saying what are they
asked the government to do to try to
help people like you and Rob I think the
thing that they're asking is for the
government to consider people that are
in our situation where you don't have a
choice you have no other way of making
any more money to come into your budget
so you are stuck so you need
help and support to take the pressure
off the hospitals to enable people to be
able to live a comfortable life we're
not asking for a luxurious life we're
just asking to keep to a a reasonable
level of warmth and to be able to eat at
a reasonable level not having to choose
between one or the other
and there's many out there like that
sure I get that Ron Maxine was saying
you're on the on the transplant list
yes I've been on the active uh this
double lung transplant for a year now so
my life could change either today
tomorrow next week I get that call and I
I will be taken to hospital for a double
lung transplant so keep me away from
infections keeping me warm is very
important to us because as Maxine said
if I got an infection it could one
reduce my lung capacity or worse it
could actually cause me it could be it
could cause end of life
yeah and you need to watch out for that
dreaded covered don't you as well and
the flu which we're being told might be
a bit of a problem this winter
um Ron can I ask how old you are
I'm 61. 61 same age as me
um and you you tend to need to stay at
home do you most of the time or can you
go out and about
in Winter we become Hermits because the
cold weather has a massive impact on run
even just walking out the door will
cause a massive coughing fit so we tend
to have to hibernate and that's what
makes this even worse because we have to
stay in and we have to keep him at a
constant temperature so that puts more
of an impact on us having to keep the
place warm it's not like we can go out a
lot and go somewhere else to keep warm
we can't
we're like Hermits I understand I
understand Maxine and I know that they
listen and watch us in number 10 what
would you like to say to them this
morning
I would like to say
I think once again you have to consider
the severely vulnerable people in this
country you've done it before and I
think you need to do it again if you
want to keep the hospitalizations down
you want to protect the older people and
the sick and poorly people and you have
to consider those people once again
because we are in a vulnerable position
once again in our lives that is putting
added pressure on a lot of people
okay Maxine um and Ron see I told you
didn't need to be nervous thanks very
much indeed for joining us on the
program uh you're yeah eloquently put
your case sir thanks a lot much
appreciated
thank you thank you very much thank you
let's look at uh other news now should
we hurricane Ian looks like it's
strengthening into a category 4 storm as
it approaches Florida
the hurricane has already knocked out
power across all of Cuba and devastated
some of the country's most important
tobacco Farms um Martha has more in
Florida with the latest
businesses here on this part of the West
Coast of Florida are preparing to close
for the last time before hurricane Ian
arrives it's expected to make landfall
towards the end of this evening into the
early hours of tomorrow morning and
people have been inside this Supermarket
buying last minute last ditch supplies
things like canned goods and Ice
anything that can see them through the
impact of hurricane Ian but potentially
the next few days as well because people
don't know the level of Destruction that
this storm will bring and it's not just
it's not just the wind the immediate
impact of the hurricane it's also the
water that they fear most here a
reasonable worst case scenario for this
area of Tampa Bay is a storm surge of up
to 10 feet just to put that in context
three feet of water makes houses
unlivable six feet is far taller than I
am and 10 feet for many people in this
area is almost Unthinkable it's been
over 100 years since the last major
hurricane made landfall in Tampa so
certainly preparations ongoing here and
you can see the the windows here boarded
up many people have been buying sandbags
fearful of the water impact so people
here hoping for the best but certainly
preparing for the worst
okay thank you now a group of women in
Berlin have come up with a new way of
raising funds for Ukraine let's have a
look should we they are donating their
wedding dresses to a pop-up store with
all the proceeds going to organizations
supporting women in the war-torn country
dresses for Ukraine has collected over
90 unique garments that will be
auctioned off and sold online to
hopefully raise tens of thousands of
Euros good for them
look great as well don't they and all
for a good cause
no plans were being told for Prince
William to receive a formal investiture
ceremony at as Prince of Wales and honor
previously granted to his father back in
1969 why let's talk to delamil
journalist and author of queen of our
times and that's Robert Todman of course
hi Robert thanks for joining us on the
program why are they not doing an
investiture do you think
well as we understand k at the moment uh
there are no plans for one I mean that
could obviously change but uh I think
there's a sense that times have moved on
uh when Prince Charles had his
investiture in 1969 uh he was very young
um it was the dawn of color television
would you believe and there was a sense
that uh that the royal family needed to
be in the sort of Forefront of this new
uh medium it was around exactly the same
time as the first Royal documentary was
shown as well
um and there was a sense that you know
this this should be a sort of a ceremony
that Blended ancient and modern it was
the first made for TV Royal ceremony
um and the government of the day were
right behind it they were very keen to
head off uh um a rising sense of Welsh
nationalism and they thought this would
be the way to do it it was very much
driven as I said by Downing Street by
the Welsh office we don't really hear
any noises about this from the current
dining Street current Welsh office Welsh
Ministry
um there's no appetite
um to have a big sort of Jamboree so I
suspect
um Prince William as we used to know him
uh do you have uh Cambridge as we used
to know now friends of Wales quite happy
to be Prince without uh filling a castle
uh and putting on robes and going
through a sort of medieval pageant yeah
Duke of Cambridge and Duke Cornwall and
now also Prince of Wales as you were
saying this is his uh uh first official
visit as Prince of Wales yesterday after
the royal family came out of the extra
week of morning although you know Wales
is is no stranger is it to this couple
they were in angles he lived in Anglesey
for a while yes I mean they're married
life began in Wales they they have a
great love of it
um Prince William as he was born uh was
always going to be uh Prince of Wales
one day
um and I think there's a sort of um it's
a two-way thing it's a it's sort of case
of of of the couple having any sort of
um jurisdiction over Wales it's it's a a
very ancient traditional title
um but it it sort of helps sort of
promote Wales you know he will know he's
already you know spent spent spent a lot
of time there the married life began
there he's a very active uh patron of
the Welsh Rugby Football Union uh you
know goes to to Welsh rugby a lot
there's there are a lot of connections
but those connections are now going to
increase I think we'll see more of the
couple in Wales they'll they'll they'll
be there more often with the children as
well
um but I I I I think he's this is an
authenticity to William I don't think he
wants any sort of synthetic sudden
pretense that he's become well she's not
suddenly gonna start speaking well
um you know depending
um you know vast amounts of of time
there it's it's an honor
um it's an ancient title
um and as I said it it it it it's good
for Wales it means whales will get a bit
more profile
um and it it it ties in
um this couple with uh with with with
their Birthright with the sort of
tradition going back the centuries
um let's let's talk about his brother uh
briefly there is a book uh that uh we
are looking forward to I'm sure the
family is as well with some trepidation
um reports that
um Harry is trying to hastily rewrite
parts of it following the death of his
grandmother what do you know
well so it is reported yeah that he
feels that after the funeral of the
queen and I think also to an extent
after the Platinum Jubilee celebrations
of the summer that perhaps
um this book
um that we are told uh is going to
contain many truths is truths uh the the
perhaps um you know that there is there
are other signs of a sort of thawing in
the in the in in the Rifts between
um the sussexes and the palace and um I
think the due wisely uh doesn't wanna
um doesn't want to burn any Bridges
um it is tricky I mean having written
one or two books myself
um you know once once the manuscript's
in you can't suddenly start making
changes at the last minute of the thing
is already at the printers
um so you may find
um that there are constraints on what
can be changed um but as we don't know
when the book was due to come out anyway
um
uh you know maybe that's easier uh what
my feeling is that there's been a lot of
speculation that he's going to cause um
you know he's going to upset
um uh members of the family I I think
the boat will be very hard hitting on
the media I think it'll be pretty hard
hitting on a lot of the palace
authorities the officials
um the gray men in suits as Harry
sometimes called them I think he's you
know Wise enough
um not to want to um blow things up
completely
um with with the family the scenes there
you're seeing you know the the the
sussexes and the cambridges
um
together at that Walkabout shortly after
the death of the queen and and I think
that the sort of direction of travel
from uh from all the sad events of
recent days
points to a a a sort of gentle warming I
mean I don't think anyone's suddenly
expecting a great reunion but um no but
it's it's heading in that direction yeah
uh we must leave it there Rob it's great
to talk to you as always thanks very
much indeed for taking the time much
appreciated thank you